uh darius welcome to the show
hey julie what's up how are you i'm
really excited to talk to you um i it's
like something i'm like oh my gosh i'm
just it's uh something i've always
wanted to do so um i appreciate that
yeah yeah i get to like watch you get
going i think you need to tell joe and
john
that we're currently running at an
all-time high in the employment cost
index that's the broadest measure of
wage inflation so they might need to
have a talk with their brother
oh they've been trying to unionize i
don't know if you've heard about that
they're mad at me now um
definitely will all right so um we're
closing out the quarter we're closing
out the first half of the year obviously
like markets have just been a steep
decline um worst for the s p about or
close at the worst
sin i don't know since 1970 so um it's
been a long time i would just love to
start with like more of like your big
picture of where we are in the markets
and maybe your outlook ahead
yeah absolutely so uh you know for those
who've been paying attention to the show
it's pretty uh pretty straightforward uh
so i'll summarize everything at 42 macro
we believe that if you use enough data
use enough math have enough of a
repeatable process you can sort of
harness these sort of big macro cycles
that tend to drive dispersion within and
across asset markets and obviously take
advantage of that uh from a portfolio
perspective just sort of you know we
consider there to be four big cycles is
the liquidity cycle so as you know if
you think about the fed balance sheet or
interest rates is that getting more
positive more favorable for asset
markets or less favorable clearly we're
in the liquidity cycle downturn our
views as we're close to let's call it
eighty five or six on that um you know
for those of you who are not americans
uh any baseball is played in nine
innings so you know probably let's call
it two-thirds of the way done in terms
of liquidity cycle downturn um as it
relates to the growth cycle which is
another important cycle we're probably
in ending four or five in the growth
cycle downturn it's set to uh
significantly uh deepen uh in the coming
months um at least according to our
forecast uh we're probably in extra
innings in the inflation cycle upturn um
as evidenced by the most recent uh pc
headline pc and headline cpi or cpi
reports that we've gotten in recent
weeks and then lastly i think we're
probably close to any one or two of the
profits cycle downturn what i mean by
profits we're talking about corporate
profits corporate earnings the things
that will drive you know incremental
decisions you know going back to your
previous discussion about uh you know
whether or not companies are spending
more money on marketing more money on
hiring etc so uh we are not in a
favorable place to be speculating uh on
the long side of most risk assets as a
function of those four uh downturns
um
so i
there's a lot of talk right now about
you know are we in a recession i will
obviously find out when we get this
second quarter gdp print but what is
kind of your thought process there and
like how do you kind of think about that
yeah so i say you guys are charts the
are you able to put them yeah we can
pull the charts up um which one would
you like us to pull up maybe the
the first one so model implied
probability yeah let's pull up the model
and model implied probabilities chart if
we can
yeah so this uh this first so what we're
trying to do with these charts is
identify uh whether or not we are in
recession or likely headed to a
recession over the medium term and some
investable time horizon anything over a
year is generally not investable from a
risk management perspective it can be
you know it's you can talk about stuff a
year from now but it's not going to
really matter to the markets um so what
i'm showing in this um in this top chart
the blue line in the upper panel just
shows the new york fed that's the
federal reserve bank of new york's
recession plot implied probability model
uh down at four percent uh four percent
probability of having a recession over
the next uh 12 months uh one i think
that number's wrong but two it's uh
significantly lower than where it's
typically at on a mean basis heading
into recession that number is around 27
so typically right into a new you know
recession that number's on average
around 27 so uh tells you a couple
things it tells you one um
at the onset of recession even the
recession probabilities are still
generally low so you need to have four
looking indicators to give you a better
uh view on that and then number two the
red line in the upper panel just shows
the uh
a model i put together just based on a
couple of bloomberg models that are
anchoring on the tens twos treasury
yield curve and the 10 year three month
treasury yield curve that procession
probability is currently around 25
percent historically it's been on
average around 35 percent at the onset
of recession so that's much closer to
signaling hey look we might actually be
a recession uh but to me i think the
discussion around recession is really
coming from the consumer um the second
chart i send you is uh consumer
confidence yeah we can pull that up too
yeah absolutely so uh the chart uh the
top upper panel on that chart shows the
blue line just shows uh conference
sports consumer confidence measure
that's sort of one of the more stickier
autocorrelated consumer confidence
measures that we have it tends to be
more correlated to the labor cycle than
the university of michigan survey which
is also why they follow that tends to be
more correlated to inflation but the key
takeaway on this chart is that
historically you've seen consumer
confidence break down below it's
trailing through your average um you're
typically in or just about heading into
recession and very clearly with the most
recent data point we got yesterday i
want to say yesterday or two days ago um
you know 99 i think we're you know we're
now careening well south of the trailing
three year average which takes me to my
final chart um consumer expectations um
you know this uh this other chart
consumer expectations uh sort of breaks
into a couple of different indices
within that consumer confidence report
um again these are these are uh june
data points so they're pretty relevant
they're pretty fresh um the red line in
the top panel just shows the present
situation index within that conference
board consumer confidence report the
blue line shows the the expectations
index so how do consumers think about
what's likely to happen over the you
know medium term and as you can see
there's because there's this massive
divergence between how consumers think
the economy is today how they feel about
the economy today relative to where they
think the economy is going to be in the
future that's denoted by the spread
there down at the bottom panel now that
spread and you know minus 80 90 basis
points wide to the negative side is
about as deeply negative has ever been
you know it's in the first percentile uh
all the monthly uh um readings since
going back to the late 60s when this
indicated when these indicators were
born so that tells you that you know as
you can see where those red bars are in
the chart historically speaking when you
get to a very deeply negative spread
between consumers expectations and how
they currently feel about the economy um
you typically are walking into recession
because that's typically how it happens
right you start feeling bad about the
future and therefore you adjust your
current spending your current um
expenditures et cetera
to how you feel and this is all part of
the behavioral dynamic associated with
you know economies of financial markets
called prospect theory we don't need to
get into that now definitely go check
out uh danny kahneman's book thinking
fast and slow if you want more details
on that i like that um and it's like
like the psychology of it um
i i guess like a follow-on to that
because like i'm looking at your models
like
is there a way to like assess um
you know how severe recession might be
like when you're looking at these in
indicators like how do you kind of think
about like is it like something that's
quick and i would love to
explore that with you
yeah so that's a great question julie so
there's a couple of ways to do that on
an ex-ante basis uh one you could sort
of you know the the the the easiest way
to do that is try to understand kind of
the different leverage psychodynamics
the first would be how fast has credit
grown
into the downturn uh historically
speaking whenever you see a significant
positive deviation uh in the in the
credit to gdp metric particularly
private non-financial sector credit to
gdp uh into a downturn that's what we
saw in 2007 um you typically get a more
deeper nastier kind of asset price led
recession that takes longer to recover
from a second way to explore that on an
ex-anti-basis is looking at the uh
looking just observance you have a
positive deviation a significantly
positive deviation from the trend in
what we call the debt service ratio so
that's the total amount of sort of
interest payments and amortization
or paying back debt um you know for the
broader private non-financial sector and
currently speaking neither of those two
um indicators are signaling kind of a
cause for significant alarm i.e neither
are suggesting that we're likely to have
a deep lasty prolonged protractor
recession which is a good thing now the
one thing i'll stop caveat this by
saying you know the data that you know
we get this uh though we derive those
statistics from are released on a pretty
severe lag so we're talking about q4 21
statistics and it's obviously the end of
the second quarter of 2022 so fast
forward six months from now we could be
getting statistics for the second
quarter of this year that may uh say
otherwise but for now um just being
data-driven we can understand that any
recession we are likely to experience
over the next 12 months or so uh should
be shallow should in my opinion i think
it's more likely to resemble the 2001
recession which was you know you got to
need a magnifying glass to you know kind
of really see it on the map it was one
it was the shallowest recession in u.s
economic history at peak to trough
decline and output of minus 70 basis
points but guess what
that didn't matter to the market
s p was cut in half nasdaq was down 80
percent in the span of that uh you know
two and a half year bear market um so
you have to be careful not to associate
your expected outcomes and financial
market terms with your expected outcomes
the economic terms the destination
doesn't have to be the same but the rate
of change is likely to sort of
perpetuate um and feed upon each other
that's interesting you say it like that
didn't matter to the market like also
just kind of makes me wonder um like say
we find out what can the we get the q2
gdp um number and it's like okay like
two consecutive quarters um of
negative um gdp growth like
do you think the market's kind of priced
in that scenario or like is there
further to go here um what do you think
yeah great question great question so so
i'll start by uh this is two things
unpack there i'll start with the first
part of your question which is in two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
that would constitute a technical
recession by the letter of the law two
consecutive quarters of contraction is a
technical recession that will not
constitute an actual recession by the
sort of market and by the federal
reserve and certainly by the people who
determine whether or not the economy's
been in recession which is the mber you
know their definition is more along the
lines of my definition of recession
which is a statistically significant
deviation negative deviation from the
trend in output um you can measure
output obviously through gdp industrial
production consumer spending consumer
income total employment all those things
tend to be correlated to the downside
and a significant deviation from their
respective trends um we have not seen
that yet however when you go back and
you think about from a technical
recession standpoint we are certainly
developing that one i mean we got the
pce data the personal consumptions
expenditure data point for the month of
may this morning and it was it was
pretty bad i it was very bad actually uh
we talked about that in our macro minute
program check out our youtube channel by
the way for those of you who don't pay
attention to those but um anyway so on a
headline basis so aggregate consumer
spending in the economy um which is two
thirds of overall gdp you know um you
know slow to 0.2 percent on a
three-month annualized basis through the
month of may and so if we stay around
these levels or if it gets you know any
worse for the month of june we will have
negative consumption growth on a
three-month annualized basis on a
quarter of a quarter basis um in the
second quarter um that's being dragged
down by goods consumption uh which is
down one point four percent on a
three-month annualized basis services
consumption is up at one percent but
guess what one percent ain't going to
cut it one that's half the trend growth
rate and number two we're supposed to be
in the middle of a services sector boom
right i mean how many stories have we
heard about you know pandemic being over
and getting on airplanes or going to
vacation we're to going out to eat you
know going to the theater et cetera et
cetera and guess what all that all that
and that narrative adds up to a mere one
percentage point um growth rate um in
three month annualized terms for
services consumption so you know we
continue to see consumers get squeezed
from a real income perspective you know
euro incomes have been basically
trending it down four percent year over
year for the last year
on either a aggregate or per capita
basis and so you know in our opinion the
data is starting to get nasty enough to
start pondering the question are we
currently in recession are we you know
getting close to entering one and i
think that the jury the the sort of um
you know the answer to that question
certainly moved in the direction of
recession very much in the last kind of
two to three hours i think that's why i
like i i love like listening to you
because i feel like i always learn
things too and you point out yeah like
there's been that narrative like oh it's
a services boom but as you point out uh
probably not the case um as it turns out
um i want to ask you about inflation too
like you mentioned we got the the pc
this morning it was it was bad i know
that's a gauge that the fed does look at
like
how do you think about inflation like is
it systemic is it baiting like
i just wonder like how you kind of begin
to assess that
yeah so inflation is very much synthetic
there's a several ways we can assess
that and not the least of which is the
data we got from this morning's report
we saw an acceleration in headline pce
inflation on both the three-month
annualized and uv rate of change terms
so that was a problem uh we saw a
re-acceleration in three-month
annualized terms in core pce which is a
fed's preferred inflation metric at 4.1
percent it's basically a double of where
the fed needs it to be so that's a
problem from the liquidity perspective
of the liquidity cycle but to answer
your questions specifically on is
inflation systemic the answer is
unequivocally yes the cleveland fed has
an index called median cpi which
measures the median rate of change in
inflation terms for everything in the
inflation basket there's hundreds you
know of indicators in the inflation
basket and what we're seeing on a median
basis not on a weighted basis on a
median basis inflation accelerate to new
all-time highs 5.5 on a year of your
basis that's a new all-time high make
6.4
on a three-month annualized basis that's
a new all-time high for that time series
so to answer your question yes we are
very much in a systemic broadening
inflation um shock on that ultimately we
think the fed is going to stick to its
guns and do something about
let's talk about the fed and um sticking
to its guns
um
j-pal we had comments from j-pal this
week um we also heard from christine
lagarde
we heard from uh boe's andrew bailey
like just kind of would love to hear
your reaction from what we're hearing
from central banks um as it relates to
some of these issues
yeah so i thought jay powell so was that
yesterday wednesday yeah the ecb forum
uh jay powell really stood out to me one
in his tone but also he made a very
important direct comment uh to financial
market participants and investors you
know to everyone in the economy and it
was it was very basic look
we are going to do whatever it takes to
get inflation back to our two percent
target that process will involve some
pain
but that it will be a worse that would
be less of a pain than just not
achieving our objective right so he's
basically saying if we allow inflation
to stick around here more people
particularly people in the low end of
the income spectrum are going to get you
know they already feel like it's a it's
a recession for them already by the way
you know some some 10 to 20 30 percent
of the economy is already in recession
just as a function of their income level
and so what he's effectively saying is
look it's going to be bad no matter what
and right now if we allow inflation to
continue to fester it's going to be bad
for the largest number of people for the
longest period of time as opposed to
just going you know tightening us into a
significant enough slowdown and output
to get us to a more um balanced supply
and demand spectrum that that will
ultimately give us better outcomes on
the inflation front so i thought that
was about as direct as i've ever heard a
central banker talk usually sorry i take
that back in hawkish terms when they
talk usually they're very direct when
they're talking about stimulating right
because they want to prevent deflation
they want asset markets to go up they
want to revive animal spirits it's very
rare that these people talk so directly
and frankly when they're actually trying
to look for lack of a better term beat
asset markets with a wooden stick yeah
i've been making this joke that palace
got this aluminum bat he's like a 12
year old at a birthday party with the
aluminum bat taking it to the pinata and
he doesn't even have a bind photo on so
he's just beating the crap out of the
pinata until the stain thing breaks i.e
inflation he's going to keep beating the
pinata yeah all the can't all the
candy's gonna be the inflation that's a
interesting visual um you just mentioned
like him being direct like just as a
market participant someone who's been in
this business for
a while like
i mean i
imagine like your peer group also was
feeling similar things like
you probably want him to be more direct
i'd imagine like do you think that
that's the kind of pal we're going to
get going forward
yeah i mean what it was so so
and sort of dating myself i found out
today i have a bald spot oh thank god
you didn't know that so i guess i have
been in this industry
for a while too
so that's either no there but yes so the
answer is yes um this is a federal
reserve don't forget i made this comment
on this program many times for the last
you know six nine months that this is a
federal reserve that is fighting two
wars not one war it's not just inflation
they're fighting the war of credibility
as well right like they spent all of
last year aggressively easing
aggressively expanding their balance
sheet to the tune of 120 billion dollars
of qe per month as inflation was
continuing to fester with this sort of
narrative that it was going to be
transitory one of the worst calls in in
financial market history let alone one
of the worst calls for the central bank
so now they're fighting to regain the
credibility associated with getting the
inflation call so wrong that call that
that was so wrong that is currently
roiling you know sort of the the budgets
of so many millions of american
households right now you know if you i
everybody watching many of the people
watching this show uh you know inflation
is a it's nuisance for a lot of us it's
not an i grew up very poor it's not a
nuisance when you're poor it is a
life-altering event you have to stop
consuming you trade down even though
you're already at the low end of the
trade down spectrum i mean if you're
buying bagged cereal because you can't
afford box cereal now you're no longer
buying cereal that's what 8.6 inflation
does in this country i'm not sure that
everyone understands that it's a really
important point that you bring up like
how it affects um like lower income
america and you just gave that that
example like let's explore that further
what could be some of the broader
consequences of that like what could
that mean for like maybe even like the
social fabric of our country
so i mean as you can see it's being
clearly reflected in in joe biden's uh
hoover rating on the broader approval
rating of congress you know obviously
there's a lot going on down there so
let's you know get too far into that but
you know it's clearly an issue i mean
this is the this is the key takeaway and
it's somebody i i'm going to misquote or
misa sign the quote but it was one of
the most um sort of
one of the most interesting things i
heard about inflation all year and i
apologize for who i'm still in school
from i'll remind everyone next thursday
but they said and i thought i agree with
it and i realized oh my god this is what
powell thinks and the quote is
when you go into recession you know the
unemployment rate backs up
two three you know forty four at a bit
worse you know four or five hundred
basis points so that's you know that
percentage of people in an economy are
going to have that that that hard time
when you have a significant inflation
shock 100 of the american citizens are
dealing with it right now so we're
talking about you know a recession being
this big boogie man that may only impact
you know significantly impact you know
let's call it three to five percent of
the economy as opposed to this inflation
which is currently impacting you know
you know skimming off the top of rich
people who don't even notice you know at
least 90 percent of the economy so i
think that's the battle they're fighting
in it to me it's a it's a much more
common sense battle
yeah
um
let's see i'm trying to think what's
let's kind of pivot a little bit and
just bring up some other um topics just
because i think it's interesting like i
like at the top of this you go over like
the indicators that you pay attention to
um
what are kind of maybe one of the
underrated signals that you look to or
pay attention to that could be helpful
for folks watching
so i mean
you know anybody who's subscribed to our
work see my work over the years or my
career you know there's not any we look
at everything i mean if there's a
statistic that matters to financial
markets or that matters to predicting
gdp to predicting cpi to predicting you
know eventually inflections in the
liquidity cycle then we're analyzing it
i mean our now cast models have
thousands of data points in them from a
fundamental standpoint our market regime
model has hundreds no sorry
1448 data points in it on a daily basis
to identify what market regime we're in
you know this is a c you know we run
serious models at 42 macros so i don't
want to give your listeners the the sort
of the the sense that oh there's one or
two things you can look at to do this at
a high level because there's not you
know it's a full-time job to to to be
average at this industry average of what
we're trying to get accomplished here
and not gonna look we've been a lot
better than average this year totally
fair enough um and then also kind of
going back to when you were showing
their models um
like how the they're when you had your
first chart how the one was kind of like
totally
off like what are they missing though in
the model like what is what is it that's
not in there
well so right now you have a pretty uh
the number one thing that will tell you
that we're unlikely to be in two things
that'll tell you we're unlikely to be in
recession right now is is corporate
profitability historically speaking
you've seen sort of a significant
decline in corporate profitability
during recession so on a trailing
12-month basis that is very much not the
case we have some pretty robust earnings
growth on a look back basis and then
second the uh the yield curve that is
typically associated with you know
timing recessions which is the 10-year
three-month treasury yield curve um that
continues to be very positively sloped
you know very wide uh yield curve uh you
know very wide you know wide yield curve
on that measure so that continues to
tell investors that hey look if we are
going to recession it's it's a ways away
it's a year away at best if not you know
maybe even two years away as a function
of that but you know i have the belief
that if you get into a significant
slowdown on growth which is what our
models are forecasting for you know
really the better part of the third
quarter and really into well into the
early part of next year
once we start to observe the economic
statistics associated with that
significant decline in output then
you're very much likely to start to see
a rally in long end of the treasury
curve while the fed is continuing to
hike and that's how you can eventually
get that inversion perhaps by the end of
the year
okay um how about in terms of i'm just
thinking back to from the beginning of
our conversation um
that i guess i i i wrote down a couple
notes here but you know anything over a
year not being investible when you're
kind of going over like the big cycles
that we're in
um
from an investment it's not that it's
not investable it's just the market
won't give a damn yeah when you talk
about the you know the market's response
to the growth cycle the inflation cycle
the profit cycle and most importantly
the liquidity cycle you when we i mean
we've back tested this as well as
anybody i've seen i mean certainly we
don't have the opportunity to look at
everyone's buy side process but
certainly i can observe what's happening
on the sales side and i think we have
some of the best back tests in the world
and our back tests show that once you
get beyond three months you know in
terms of you know a look forward markets
don't really have any response to those
kinds of dynamics right and so if you're
talking about like liquidity cycle
growth cycle pow inflation growth having
an impact on asset markets it's usually
within the next few months that the
market is trying to you know fill around
and price in it's not the next two to
three years you know the you know that
stuff will happen along the way you know
the catalysts are you know drive you
higher drive you lower along the way
that's a good point yeah it's happening
um i guess
much more i guess closer to where we are
uh than than further out um
i do want to just ask like maybe um
from an investment perspective like
i don't know if you could share like
like what where would you want to be
like right now like
yeah i mean so
you know
out of respect for our paying
subscribers and we're very appreciative
of them you know i'm not going to give
too specific of advice but you have one
thing i'll say um you know just
something i've been saying in the
program all year which is cash is king
in an environment like this you don't
need when you're in a quick simultaneous
liquidity cycle downturn growth cycle
downturn and profit cycle downturn you
know few things in in the history of
asset markets are as negative for risk
assets as those things being you know in
that state in that condition all at the
same time and so you know if you came
into the year looking backwards you know
we're in a growth cycle upturn liquidity
cycle upturn everything was the
liquidity bonanza i mean it wasn't up
terms of bonanza some of the most
aggressive easing we've ever seen um out
of the federal reserve in the history of
that institution you know so it's it was
you know if you were whatever risk you
were running whatever you know capital
risk you were running in that
environment it needs to be significantly
curtailed to risk manage this
environment i mean just be just have
less risk on is the number one the
answer to your question then obviously
you know which is called we made going
back to november of last year the higher
beta the more volatile the things that
go up the most of the markets going up
the most tend to go down the most when
the market's going down and so we made a
call that hey say hey if you have a lot
of high beta assets in your portfolio
you need to get rid of them because the
market is going to sell them and
ultimately obviously it continues to
sell them to this day yeah um i want to
bring it up with you just because of
like you know the makeup of our audience
is just like kind of your views on i
don't know if you what your latest is on
bitcoin i'm just looking at the price
right now it's just under
19 000 so it's 18 930 and some change
right now what are your kind of your
views just it's i think it's on track
it's going to be it's i want to say it's
like worst month at least in a long time
so worst quarters since 2011. there you
go see yeah
yeah so uh so bitcoin i i'm
i'm concerned uh i mean i don't want to
scare i know this is a bitcoin friendly
program i myself am a bitcoiner um but
i'm definitely concerned and here's why
we made a call going back to april that
we thought the support
support for bitcoin where you would back
the truck up and buy it was 19 000. uh i
am shocked
that we are here so fast i am absolutely
shocked that we have gotten down here so
quickly and that tells me that if
nineteen thousand doesn't hold
i don't know pick up pick a round number
fifteen thousand ten thousand i don't
know there's no support once you break
19 does at least not in terms of our
analysis and so you know we talk about
this liquidity cycle downturn let's not
forget that we're only doing about half
the total amount of quantitative
tightening that the fed intends to
initiate you know in over the course of
the medium term so by september we're
going to double the pace of quantitative
tightening from draining 45 billion uh
45 billion of liquidity out of the
market for lack of a better phrase um to
95 billion um that's that's as fast
that's like as fast as a fed has ever
drained liquidity from the market by a
double and so my point of bringing up is
that when you factor that in you factor
in the over capitalization of the
treasury as a function of you know the
and the t bill's shortest as a result of
that and ultimately the the rapidly
rising uptake in the fed's reverse
rebuild facility balance all these
dynamics are sort of combining to drain
massive amounts of liquidity from
financial markets and so if you do the
math on our analysis you know we get to
about you know basically you know just i
have a trillion dollars of liquidity is
going to get drained from financial
markets between now and you're in if the
fed stays on this course and if the
dynamics with the reverse report
facility don't materially change if that
happens fair value on the s p 500 is 2
900. so guess where bitcoin is going to
be on a correlation weighted basis if
the market declines uh significantly
from here
i'm just looking
right now um
you said a trillion
it's 915 billion to be exact so
okay okay i know i'm i
guess like the quick following question
too like when you talk about the
liquidity cycle downturn you said the
top of this program we're in the fifth
or sixth inning um does it accelerate
over time does he get like
as you go through that cycle like how
does that kind of how does that play out
is it like a smooth thing or does it
just like smile and get worse and worse
as you get further in the cycle
i'd love for it to be smooth but the
reality is you know we get to 4 30 in
the morning every day because it's not
smooth it's non-linear
markets are you know they're dynamic
ecosystems and so the reality is you
know one acceleration and one factor can
lead to a deceleration another factor
and vice versa one thing we know we're
going to get is we're very likely to get
a a a reduction in the size of rate
increases particularly after we get past
this july 27 that fomc meeting i'm not
so sure we're going to get another 75
base point rate hike i mean maybe it's
75 but i think you know by the time we
get there it could be 50 if we get a
couple of decent inflation prints we get
june cpi on the 13th maybe we get some
decline significant decline in crude oil
into the summertime potentially i don't
know i'm not making that call
that could cause the fed to go to 50 in
july 27 but the reality is you know
we're not going to stick at 75 75 75
that's unlikely um so you know we're
going to see a slow down in the in the
in the pace of rate hikes but we're at
the same time we're going to get an
acceleration in the the quantitative
tightening program so you know on that
generally speaking quantitative
tightening has a more of a near-term
sort of coincident impact on asset
markets qe and qt than interest rate
hikes and interest rate cuts
just like on
you mentioned the inflation print do you
have like a kind of a number in mind
like i don't i don't know if you
actually mentioned a specific number but
what do you kind of think in there
for headlines cpi we are at
try and pull up our estimates now
we're sticking at 8.6 for june or yeah
sorry yeah for june yeah so that number
be out on um on july 13th gotcha um any
parting thoughts before i let you go
yeah um this is this is not the time to
be cavalier um i know a lot of folks
have um probably this first half of the
year has not gone the way they probably
hoped and that's okay um you know not
everything in life is gonna go the way
you hope but the most important you know
thing you need to make is you need to
make a decision and determination on
what is your next play you know
sometimes you give up a sack sometimes
you give up a touchdown but at the end
of the day the game is not over you have
to make a decision on how to regroup
refocus your reallocate your focus
budget so that you can take advantage of
the next series of opportunities and
catalysts and markets and if you don't
know what those opportunities and
catalysts are then come check us out at
42 macro if not just so catch back here
next week i love that well i was going
to ask you where can folks find you
online so you mentioned 42 macro uh let
yeah let folks know where they can find
you and learn more
yeah so uh come check us out at
42macro.com if you're a serious investor
what i mean by serious investors someone
who has legitimate investment objectives
you know serious size in terms of their
asset allocation in terms of their
capital risk um would be professional
you can be non-professional you know
both obviously as subscribers and if
then obviously if you're either
non-serious investors someone who can't
afford a college student et cetera then
come follow us on twitter we put out a
lot of research on our uh youtube
channel as well so you know we
definitely have something for everybody
but i i definitely think this is the
time where if you don't have a
legitimate macro process heading into
the second half of this year
you will struggle that's a guarantee
yeah they can also find you on twitter
as well we just showed you 42 macro
details amazing well darius dale founder
and ceo42macro i thank you so much for
your time and your fascinating um
discussion and just also the way you end
things with like those parting words of
wisdom for everyone really puts things
in perspective so thanks again
of course julia look forward to next
time cheers